there are two types of people that you
can hire I'm going to share who they are
and who you should hire on this video
today so really God asks a question one
of my YouTube followers love you guys
Jay like dekha wrote in to ask me this
excellent video Thank You Jay I haven't
look at this type of hierarchy before
haven't you had to figure out each task
and step-by-step it before handling the
job for someone else to do or should I
say I need these numbers here my bank
accounts create the records thanks Jacob
so Jacob there are two types of people
that you can hire are not going to help
you figure out today which one you need
for your business so the first type of
person is you hire for tasks and these
are people who you know exactly what you
need to get done you have a certain
process that you follow maybe you're the
expert at it you've created the system
and all you need people to do is follow
the system so if that's what you need
for your bank records and you tell them
I need you to go to this bank account
pull out this information and give me
this report by this day and you can
explain how to do it and what to do then
you're hiring that person just lower
specific tasks and don't sleep or needed
in your business the second type of
person is to hire for projects and these
are the people you hire when you don't
quite know how to accomplish the goal
you have a goal but you don't know the
steps to get there so you can't show
them how to do it so here's an example
here's a devil from today I wanted to
make my videos better Christina my
editor is going on and on and on about
how my videos are not in focus and
they're not perfect and all these issues
that are on with them and I appreciate
it if she wants and videos to get better
so today I hired a videographer to come
in the lady is here with me shooting
behind the camera and he's making the
videos look better he's putting mean
focused he's switching the angles he's
telling me all the things that I don't
know right if I came in and told him hey
I need you to do this and this only then
I'm hiring a tax taker and I don't know
what I'm talking about right I'm not the
professional video guy so I'm hiring him
for his expertise and that's what you
need to do if you really want to take
your business up to the next level you
want to hire people for projects and not
for tasks so at the end of then you're
going to need both you're going to need
the people
take those tasks off your plate and
you're going to need the people who can
take the projects and help you run with
it the tasks again de where you're given
specific criterion say go do this and
the projects are saying here's my goal
of what I want to accomplish help me get
there you will need both of your
business but you have to make sure that
you don't just hire the task people
that's a mistake a lot of entrepreneurs
fall into they think they know
everything and they just hire the people
who know the tasks to come in and do
exactly as they did it but in reality
you also need to bring on the people who
know more than you and you can take the
project and run with them because that's
how you're really going to see
significant growth for your business
believe for those you're watching I'd
love to know who have you hired in your
business are you hiring the task people
or the project people leave it in the
comments below I want to see I'm going
to join in that discussion with you
thank you so much for watching continue
to believe and I'll see you soon